so I wanted to start by telling you
something that happens six days ago at X
which was a little bit unusual and then
maybe we can go back a little bit and
unpack how something like that happened
so we have these audacious goals Awards
once a quarter we get together and
everyone presents how they're doing and
there's a trophy the trophy hasn't been
given out in a year now because it's
really hard to get this trophy and I'll
talk a little bit about what it takes to
get this trophy I think people care a
lot I've seen a team cry and this was a
team of patent lawyers by the way who
weeping they were so happy when they got
this trophy so we had our read back from
q1 that happened just Thursday last week
and very unusually three different teams
potentially merited that trophy usually
it's nobody that's why we haven't given
out in the year so the Star Chamber
which was me and my admin Sergio did
went and like huddled and decided who
actually deserved it picked the one of
the three teams that we thought actually
had been the most audacious of the three
that had potentially earned it and then
awarded them the trophy at the end of
the all hands and the person came up to
accept the ward who is sort of like the
main lieutenant for that group because
the head of the group I wasn't there at
the time and he took it he said thank
you and then he said but I don't think
that we're doing good enough I don't
think we've been honest enough I'm
handing it back to you it's like we
can't give me a word away it's been a
year since anybody got it in and and
this was with many many hundreds of
people watching people been waiting all
year why would someone hand the award
back so I want to take a step back now
and tell you the thing that excites me
the most this is some of the stuff that
I couldn't get into the TED talk which I
gave recently in Vancouver that's up
online now but that in
some ways because it was a TED talk has
to skim the surface of the stuff that
I'm most excited about and not get into
some of the details I'm a culture
engineer the thing that excites me the
most is not making stratospheric
balloons or self-driving cars or working
on contact lenses or on UAVs that can
deliver packages the thing that excites
me the most is trying to systematize
innovation and when I was young I used
to think that systematizing innovation
might be some combination of things you
could get if you just went to all the
business books and you picked out the
smartest things from each of the
business books hire the smartest people
and fail fast and this and that and the
other thing is kind of true it just
turns out that if you do that you don't
actually get much innovation what
excites me is what would it take to
actually get a peep a group of people to
do the things that it says in those
business books that you guys have all
read if this is the set of things they
should do and this is the set of things
they do do and for any of you who've
been in business before you know how big
a gulf there is wherever you work I
promise you that Gulf existed there's a
reason that there's such a big gap
between the things that that you want
them to do and the things they actually
spend their time doing it's because this
is the lip service that you're giving
but this is this paths of least
resistance emotionally to doing those
things they don't care what you said
they should do they're going to follow
the paths of emotional least resistance
cultural engineering is the process of
trying to get this the paths of least
resistance to actually line up with the
things you want them to do so I'm going
to give you a few examples um so then
the first one is let me unpack a little
bit more about the audacious goals so
here's how most companies do
something sort of like the audacious
goals if you guys heard of okay ours
objectives and key results so this is
the way objectives and key results
actually works in a business you are
going to need to be you report to me and
you're gonna have to be held accountable
by me because I'm the manager so we're
going to start this weird haggle
situation you we're going to figure out
what your ok ours are you're going to
try to haggle them as low as you can
sandbag sandbag sandbag because you know
I'm going to hold you accountable for
whatever it is that we decide on so that
i can feel you pulling them down so i'm
going to pull them up up up up up I want
to haggle haggle haggle you can do more
you can do more you're sandbagging and
we end up in this place in the middle
we're now you feel like you don't really
own that ok are it's higher than the
things that you were saying and you were
making all these arguments about why
that's an unreasonable number of metric
for me to hold you too it's either the
wrong metric or it's too big relative to
what you think you could actually
accomplish and I feel bad too because I
feel like it's two-thirds or half of
what I actually was trying to talk you
into so now we have this thing that
neither of us believes in and this is
the OKR this is a stick it's a weapon
and my management plan for the entire
quarter or year is I'm going to beat you
with the OKR stick you're not doing it
enough you're not doing it enough this
is 21st century management somehow it
doesn't work very well this is not how
to get people to be innovative you
cannot get them to do the things you
really want them to do especially if
your lip service includes things like
creativity and failing fast and being
transparent and a lot of emotionally
hard things while you're beating them
with the OKR stick crazy idea what if
instead you just got to pick what you
were going to do let's call it your
audacious goal for the quarter it's your
goal I'm not going to haggle with you
about it you pick it you get up in front
of all of us once a quarter and say I'm
going to try to get this thing done and
i know that i'm almost certain not to
get it done but i'm proud of the fact
that i'm going to
try to do something that sounds so crazy
hard so unlikely the goal is to have it
be something that you can accomplish
about one-tenth of the time I mean if
you're positive you're not going to
accomplish it that's not very
interesting you're not really going to
try on the other hand if you're
confident you're going to do it it's not
audacious by definition so you want it
to be in that sort of ten percent range
and you're going to end up getting held
accountable by yourself because you
picked it and by the whole community
because you want everyone to be proud of
you now I can be your coach and mentor
instead of having to beat you with the
OKR stick so at X we have audacious
goals and every quarter every team gets
up and says here is what our aday shis
goal for the quarter was here's how we
did against it and here's what we're
going to try to do for the next quarter
and some teams don't do it some quarters
and that's actually okay too they don't
look as audacious when they don't do it
but that's fair game because you need to
be crisp about what you're going to do
if you're going to try to do it so now
think in that context that after a year
of not handing this out we offered some
won the trophy and they said no thank
you we're not being audacious enough
somehow they've internalized something
really deep and meaningful they were
actually one-upping me on the things I'm
trying to get X to be like that's when
the magic starts happening when the
flywheel is speeding itself up and so
you don't have to keep speeding it up
that's great corporate culture that's
what you want to unlock in any
organization that you're part of or that
you're overseeing how did that happen
let me give you two or three other
examples of the kinds of things that
might have led to this person grant
saying no thank you and handing the
trophy back to me so one of them is you
know fail fast Lean Startup pretotyping
I don't know which ones of these things
you've heard recently they're all fine
they're all true it's it's that
it doesn't make it happen I'm going to
tell you something else that we do and
afterwards it will sound kind of
shocking and yet basic i encourage you
to find anywhere else that has actually
done this when one of our projects that
actually has like a non-trivial number
of people least a few people full time
on it ends their project and they end
their projects i'll tell you a story
about that we bring them up and stay on
stage we have a bunch of Xers here
they've seen this multiple times we
bring them up on stage and we say this
team is ending their project today they
have done more in ending their project
in this quarter than any of you did to
further innovation at x in last quarter
and then all of your especially the
first time you hear this are going to
feel a little ripped off like wait a
second they're failing they're calling
it a day i'm working my ass off how come
they're up on stage that seems kind of
unfair then i say and we're giving them
bonuses obviously wait I'm not getting a
bonus why they get a bonus they're
killing their project I'm actually
succeeding mine still going you know
what guys take a vacation and when you
come back the world's your oyster you'll
find some new project to start or you
can pick which project to jump into
depending on which one's going best at
this point all of you are a little
mystified if this is your first time
through this and feeling quite ripped
off but social norms are incredibly
powerful people will do horrible
horrible things to each other if you set
the social norms appropriately they will
also do incredibly innovative creative
expressive transparent things if you
create the right norms for it by the
10th time that we do this it's normal I
don't even have to remind people anymore
when we stand them up that they should
get a huge round of applause and that
everyone there should be looking up to
the people who ended the projects but
have you ever heard of somebody actually
getting rewarded
if I tell you to fail fast are you gonna
run out if you're part of our
organization and fail fast just because
I said it no you're going to be thinking
what happens if I fail fast am I going
to get fired I mean I'm going to lose
all the people reporting to me right so
then I suck and then up like go tell you
know like my friends I was kind of
demoted am I going to get my bonus at
the end of the year well like what
happens to my compensation or my my
opportunity for promotion are those
things all out the window this is the
difference between the lip service and
the actual emotional paths of least
resistance creating the feeling that
failing fast would actually get you what
you want instead of getting you the
opposite of what you want so here's a
story for how one of these teams got up
on stage in the first place I was
sitting with maybe 30 of them we've been
working for about two months their
manager there the general manager for
this project hadn't been working out
great eventually we had to to move that
person out of the organization I had
become the temporary general manager I
already could kind of smell where things
were going but I didn't want to prejudge
I said look we're going to decide
whether this is going to the moon or
whether we're going to call it a day you
guys need to come to me with that
decision and they were having a hard
time doing that and they were working on
kind of some business planning and
technical planning and sort of
restructuring their thinking and
eventually they got me a doc it was
seriously that thick 30 people in the
room we all sat down I think they
thought I'd pre-read the doc I really
hadn't even cracked it and I said all
right who's with me we're all going to
spend the next 18 you know years or our
lives if that's what it takes to cause
this to change the world 18 hours a day
if that's what it takes we will quit X
all of us and go do this who's with me
no one's hand went up I just waited I
hadn't looked at the business
I just kept waiting maybe good 30
seconds a minute which was very long
when you're all just sitting there I'm
the only one of my hand up and I said
sounds like you guys need to talk
amongst yourselves a little bit I went
away they called me about three hours
later and said okay come back and I came
back and they said yeah you're right I
hadn't actually I said we should leave I
and they said it's good but it's not
great like we don't really think it's
that great a business awesome that
wasn't so bad Addie's sitting right
there was in the room for that and was
part of the Shepherd of helping them
during the three hours I wasn't there
come to that conclusion but they said it
to me when I say it to them they've been
fired they've been demoted their project
has been ruined because they have no
ownership of that moment but when they
say yeah you're right they're taking
ownership of their own time of their own
lives which believe me is the only
really precious thing when you're pretty
good but not great project is over
you're not just going to go sit in a
corner and do nothing afterwards you're
going to get on to something that's
better than that almost by definition if
it was a good but not great project and
that they owned that then they didn't
feel like it was being rest away from
them and then they got stood up in front
of X and congratulated and bonused and
vacationed and you know what most of
those people I think like all but one or
two of those people are still somewhere
in Alphabet a decent number of them are
still an X there was actually a whole
group that sort of recombined around a
new project that actually went
fabulously well and we've now graduated
out of X to another part of alphabet and
I think that they're super happy and we
gave them hugs on their way out and
begged them to come back when they're
done with that thing and ready for
another tour of duty at X this is not a
failure moment the word failure and
trying to get people to fail is a bit of
a misnomer first of all it's missing
this path of least resistance issue
because people don't want to do it
failure when it's actually just you got
a negative result for no reason and it's
meaningless is a bad thing I am NOT pro
failure I'm pro learning another thing
that we talked about allotted X you guys
can all probably run this experiment in
your own mind especially if you've been
at work somewhere for at least a few
years imagine a project that took a
non-trivial amount of time to do at
least months think about when you were
done you and probably a group of other
people but even just by yourself when
you're done you lose all the code all
the tools whatever it is but you still
remember having finished and and what it
took to finish it if you had to build it
from scratch whatever it was it's in
your mind right now how long would that
really take to do it again ten percent
of the time is the first time we have a
name for the other ninety percent and we
could call it wasted time but that's not
really what it was you were learning
what the right thing to do is innovation
is that ninety percent it's how much you
can either compress the time and that
ninety percent or compress the cost of
that ninety percent that's it that's
innovation and that's why failure
matters that's why we send people out to
fail but we don't mean go not to be good
that's not what we mean by suggesting
that failure is positive we mean find
incredibly efficient ways to learn time
efficient or cost-efficient waves to
learn and then you have to create these
opportunities for them to feel good
about it like some of the ones that I
just described to you another one that
we're trying right now I think it's
working pretty well but maybe the the
jury's not totally in on this one yet is
you guys have heard of post mortems
maybe some of you have done post mortems
a post-mortem is you wait till
something's dead and then you look at
you know it being dead and you talk
about why it died and you try to learn
something from the fact that it's dead
so that you can you know kill it you
know faster or
is it not to be dead or its equivalent
the next time you learn from the death
that's why it's a post-mortem after
death we're doing pre mortems a
pre-mortem is nothing other than trying
to talk about the learning moment of a
failure before we actually have the
failure we're so eager to learn from our
failures we don't want to wait till the
failure happens to learn from it it
introduces a little bit of like one of
those time machine movie questions we're
like if you actually then address it and
then the failure doesn't happen maybe it
never would have happened in the first
place so it's a you don't get a good
control experiment for these things but
actually saying to everybody in the
organization let's talk about what's
wrong with us not in a survey monkey
kind of way but like let's really talk
about it tell me what you think is the
biggest risk for our organization
overall or for Project loon or for the
self-driving car project tell me why
we're going to fail when we fail three
years from now what will that be in your
opinion write it down put it up there
with your name on it which is a little
bit scary because some people can feel
thrown under the bus when you actually
call out these Achilles heels that you
see or that you think might be there
then have a mechanism which we do so you
can just vote these up or down which
causes the things that more people think
are actual risks even if you didn't
write it down email yeah I agree I agree
I agree with these and not with those no
I don't think those are problems it
causes the stuff that's probably the
biggest risks to rise to the surface and
then there's commenting mechanisms so
people can actually discuss it only if
you get thrown under the bus you say
that you know project loon is going to
have some problem and you say what it is
and you work on project loon and then
people go after you about it if our
culture isn't one that rewards you for
doing that that's the last time you're
going to do that so making a mechanism
like that actually isn't the hard part I
think
it's a good thing it's working for us
but the hard part is relentlessly and
repeatedly chasing down those moments
where it's not working he needs a hug if
he said something brave on that site I
mean a physical hug an actual hug or a
high five or whatever and then if he
actually gets a hard time from someone
for having written that down what are we
all going to do to defend him not just
because he's right he's probably wrong
well like we don't know there's a lot of
smart people on the Loon project I'm
sure they've already thought of it but
thank you for saying that whether or not
you're right so I'm going to give you
one or two more of these things and then
I'm going to open it up for questions so
you guys can start thinking about some
of this stuff but let me describe for
you a little bit about the process that
we have for going through these things
because now that I've given you a flavor
for how we're trying to set the
expectations at X it might make a little
bit more sense so we have a team which
is called the rapid eval team the rapid
eval team supposed to take ideas from me
from you guys literally from the
founders at alphabet anywhere they can
get their hands on an idea it doesn't
matter where the idea is there's an
academic at at Berkeley or Stanford or
johns hopkins great every place is a
legitimate place for great ideas to come
from how can we figure out as fast as
possible that that's a bad idea that is
absolutely and explicitly the question
it sounds like that's not going to work
later ever just say everything is a bad
idea but if you set the tone the way
I've just described it people are
actually interested in coming up with a
real reason why it's a bad idea you
can't destroy the positivity that comes
from saying crazy ideas but if you say
to me hey ridiculous idea do you think
we could get the power that's embodied
in an avalanche somehow gathered maybe
that's like a way to generate energy the
correct answer no
matter what she said is that's an
awesome idea she has to feel good about
the level of creativity of right i mean
if she said something it's like actually
there's 100 companies already doing that
and you you purchase something from them
yesterday then maybe that's not an
awesome idea but assuming that it's
really outside the box the correct first
answer the only acceptable first answer
is wow it's beautiful the way your brain
works then immediately that's so great
how are we going to figure out that
that's a bad idea that that's not going
to work so she just got a little check
mark with myself with her peers for
having said something that was really
interesting it was innovative that was
different than what we were thinking
before and immediately she now also gets
to not get another check mark if she can
show the intellectual rigor for why it's
a bad idea well okay like I guess we
could try to generate avalanches you
know and like we had like how much is in
an avalanche is it's good it's not great
okay well maybe we could like move the
thing that's going to turn all that
potential energy and kinetic energy into
you know lots of like stored energy
maybe like we'll move it around so we
can get like the avalanches as they fall
now that's not really going to work it
won't take us but five minutes to sort
out that there's probably no practical
way to do that good awesome we've
figured out rigorously not just in our
gut that that's not going to work and we
can move on because the rate-limiting
step to innovation is not finding smart
people you're all plenty smart enough it
is not being creative how many people
here in this room think that you're
highly creative good
the other half of you were wrong you're
all highly creative how many of you
think you were creative when you were
six who wasn't creative when there were
six years old i mean you don't have a
six-year-old if you think they weren't
creative when you were six we just get
it beaten out of us by society I promise
you you were creative when you were six
years old we all were we've just
forgotten how because it with the
context isn't inspiring us isn't
allowing us it's literally blocking us
but that's not the problem the problem
is how to get a huge number of ideas on
the table and then weed through them
effectively which is not about process
it's about creating an environment where
people feel like they can be rewarded in
emotional ways and financial ways for
doing that a tiny fraction of these
ideas then pass through to our sort of
second stage booster rocket which we
called foundry in the first stage most
of the de-risking that we do is on the
technical front building prototypes
verifying that it's not some isomorphism
to like perpetual motion machine you'd
be surprised probably one in a hundred
of the ideas we get literally is an
isomorphism to a perpetual motion
machine once something gets to foundry
maybe twenty thirty percent of the work
is still very technical but a lot more
of the work then gets applied to what is
the ecosystem like and the regulatory
environment how much would we have to
invest versus how sizeable business
would this be how much good would this
really do for the world if we didn't do
this would the world end up with that
benefit anyway for some other reason or
not working through all of those reasons
again for the purpose of killing the
project even in foundry which is
supposed to only receive things that
have been heavily weeded the goal is to
have more than half of those projects be
killed when you hit more than half
you're clearly in a mode where the
people in foundry understand even though
they can be very passionate about the
projects they're working on that there's
less than a fifty percent chance of
doing it so they can take pride in
ending the projects for the right
reasons
I mean eventually you know for the
self-driving cars i'm pretty sure cars
are going to drive themselves since cars
are already driving themselves you know
for Project loon we have a lot of
balloons up in the air if they're
already doing LTE to the ground people
are actually like receiving phone calls
so we know it's possible kind of the
ship has sailed pun intended a little
bit on some of that stuff but for a long
time the pressure is not how can we make
this work it's how can we discover as
fast as possible this is not going to
work so that we can get on to doing
something else I'm happy to keep going
but do you guys have questions I want to
make sure that I shape some of this for
the stuff that you guys are thinking
about doing alright cool points for the
first question yeah how would you apply
this to big projects namely something
where you want to put a man on the moon
or do a manhattan project or have you
thought about say Einstein's comment
that it's ninety percent perspiration
rather than ten percent inspiration in
other words the Devils in the detail the
hard part is doing it as opposed to
thinking of it ideas are a dime a dozen
right well actually i agree i just gave
you an estimate which was also ninety
percent believe me we do a ton of
perspiring i'm describing that ninety
percent the learning part as the
perspiring because that ninety percent
you guys all know from whatever it was
that was the last hard project you did
you didn't just sit there in navel gaze
for that ninety percent of the time you
thought you had the right answer and you
perspired and you did stuff and it
didn't work out and you're like a home
and it didn't work out and then you have
to learn and iterate that process which
is the perspiring that's what I'm
talking about what I'm describing is
exactly the process of saying whether
you're making a rocket to go to the moon
or you're making a car that drives
itself what might cause this to fail
let's set up hypotheses dear questions
let me give you another example I've run
this experiment many times with
different groups at X make me a list of
the top 10 things that your team needs
to do no problem
stroh and we get this list and is
invariably ordered by the things they
think will be most important will be
most well received by the market
whatever that is Thanks all right now
humor me reorder that list instead of
most important at the top make it the
thing at the top is the one that would
cause us to learn the most and the one
at the bottom is the one that will cause
us to learn the least they reorder the
list and is invariably a different
ordering of the list okay why don't you
just do the first two things on the list
just humor me just do the first two
things on that new list and then we do
them and then I say make me a top ten
list of the things you think are most
important forget the learning stuff now
and they do and that new list is
unrecognizably different from the
previous list of 10 things that they
made and then I say that's why we focus
on learning because if we hadn't done
that you would have done all 10 things
on that list and somewhere in that list
you would have run across the things
that actually caused you to learn such
that the rest of the things on the list
turned out to be irrelevant why wouldn't
you try to bubble those two things to
the top of the list always this is not
about being smart this is not about
being smart it's not about being
creative it's about choosing to spend
your time on that and I cannot
overemphasize you cannot just tell
people to do what I just told them to do
this is if feel free to take the idea
and run with it you will discover that
it doesn't work not because it's not
true but because people won't do it it
will be maddening to you I promise you
as a young entrepreneurs you will
discover that people don't do it and it
will make your head explode that they
won't do i'm speaking from personal
experience the reason they won't do it
is because put yourself in their shoes
if you don't have someone who's ranting
the way i'm ranting right now if you do
the things on that first list the
important stuff you get the important
stuff done after a couple months you
bring it to your boss to the CEO of your
business and you say look what I built
you got important stuff done good job
man
Hey look what I built if you follow that
second thing I just proved that we're
totally wasting our time and we're gonna
have to start over you really think that
they're gonna get a thank you cuz they
don't think they're gonna get a thank
you and if they don't think they're
going to get a thank you they're not
going to do it that's it that's the hard
part it's not the reordering of the list
it's creating the culture where people
are willing to listen to you about the
reordering of the list other questions
yeah thinking of this from a post-mortem
point of view what do you think are the
biggest challenges or causes of failures
for a skunk work or organization like X
to operate within a bigger companies
such as Google um one of the challenges
for doing something yes sure i will
repeat it i mean the question is what
are some potential failure modes for
doing something like x inside a larger
you know entity like alphabet and i'm
not sure that this is a complete list
but if you are coupled too tightly to an
organization if you're busy trying to
solve their problems for them then their
needs can whip saw you in various ways
that can be productive in the good cases
where you actually solve one of their
problems then they'll really appreciate
it and you have the sort of ready market
for your thing that you made because
they already needed it and you don't
have to think about what's hard and
important you just have to think about
whether you can make the thing that they
know that they need but in the end
businesses tend to be somewhat like
sigmoid right they're flat for a while
they go up really steeply and then they
taper off in you know in the long run
and the way businesses continue to grow
in the longer term is by having more
than one problem to have so X's mission
is to find some new problems for you
know us more generally to have four
the larger entity to have and if that's
our goal to find new problems for us to
have we can't be overly constrained by
what they think their problems are today
so it's a failure mode to be maybe too
tightly coupled I also think it's a time
horizon issue everything that I I've
just told you I do believe very deeply
but it's probably not the right thing to
do if you have to you know declare
victory in cash in in three months over
sufficiently short time horizons
empowering people and trusting people is
probably a waste of time over very short
time horizons you should probably just
find the rock stars and you know use
fear and greed to get them to get stuff
done I think it's probably over
sufficiently short time horizons I think
that's probably the right thing to do
the opposite is also true if you have
decades you cannot over trust and over
empower people even if somebody spends a
half a year learning and growing and
they waste some of the entities money in
the process of doing that if you really
have many decades before you have to
declare victory you'll get paid back
many times over because of that growth
because of how empowered they feel now
the truth is time horizons are usually
somewhere in between weeks and many
decades but if you set the time horizon
wrong I think that can also potentially
be a failure mode X is time horizon I
would describe like this we are looking
for things that can really have a huge
meaningful impact on the world within
about five to ten years but if somebody
were to bring me and we do this
experiment frequently when we have two
things this one maybe could change the
world in four years but we won't know
for three and a half if it's any good
this one could take 10 years to change
the world but we'll learn something
every six months about whether we're on
the right path forget that one the
difference between five or ten years
we're kidding ourselves that we can even
tell right now whether it's going to
take five or ten i want the one where we
can learn along
the way not where it's this one-shot
thing where we find out after three and
a half years have we've been wasting our
time or not so I would say that's
another potential failure mode is ending
up where you think you're a skunk works
but you're not a learning organization
you're a take big risks blindly
organization which is probably not how I
would suggest doing it yeah what might
be the most impressive proposal er idea
that's dummy other impressive proposal
oh yeah so the question was what's the
most impressive proposal that's come my
way you know this might be an
unsatisfying answer but I don't I don't
judge it that way and I don't I hope
nobody at X does either I think you
might be surprised how much it feels
collegial at X because there's as soon
as you allow too much one-upsmanship to
enter the process dangerous things
happen people start trying to get that
award and we don't want them to want
that org I gave you this example before
about the Avalanche it's a I like that
as an example because it's different not
because she was right but because she
was way outside the box someone else it
wasn't her it was someone else asked
some a different question which is could
you put a ring of copper around the
north pole or the South Pole I guess and
use the Earth's magnetic flux right the
the molten core of the earth kind of
sloshes back and forth a little bit and
you get sort of moving be filled which
would generate a current in this huge
piece of copper that you put around
Santa Clauses house and then you could
pipe that current back down here it
turns out not to work but I mean it
works it just it's not at all cost
effective but it actually would generate
electricity AC obviously but a very slow
foot wave la see
I love those questions because they they
make me believe that we haven't even
scratched the surface of our collective
creativity as a species yet and it's
important because it shapes something
about X part of what I've just described
about killing these projects as fast as
we can has a hidden assumption in which
I believe very strongly but you have to
believe this in order for what I've just
described to be right the cost of a
false positive at X at any innovation
factory is huge relative to the cost of
a false negative a false positive is
where we think we have a great idea and
it's not a great idea that's a false
positive well if we think it's a great
idea when it's really not we're spending
money we're spending money we're
spending money is all this management
time the team keeps growing and we're
wasting all of our money because at
least in this thought experiment it's a
bad idea what's the cost of a false
negative if we say that something which
is actually a great idea we look at it
we say no that's not a great idea that's
only a cost to us if there's a really
limited supply of great ideas of really
big problems with really innovative
solutions sadly humanity is in no danger
of running out of huge problems to work
on and I really don't believe that we're
in any danger of running out of really
interesting incredibly different
potential solutions and because both of
those things are so rich in such great
supply that false negatives cost us
almost nothing relative to the false
positives better to lean fairly heavily
towards the false negatives rather than
the false positives yeah to the
pre-mortem and you said you had the
thumbs up John to get things to welcome
to the top what do you do with the
things of bubble to the top uh of right
so the question is in these pre mortems
when a bunch of people vote up something
there's now fifty or a hundred people
who said yeah I agree that might be a
big risk for X or for Makani are
airborne wind turbine project
first of all we take it seriously like
we look at it more number two it depends
because sometimes they have very
different characteristics if it was you
know we're going to run out of space
right then if that's a facilities issue
then that's not like kind of a panic
like we need to tell the facilities
person that like Makani might not even
need to be involved in that particular
case or you know if it's more of like a
whistleblowing thing where it's I think
we're going so fast that we might be
cutting corners on safety okay you can't
just send that over to Makani as a whole
and expect the right results you might
want to cherry-pick the person there who
is responsible for safety and say what
do you think about this what kind of
pressure are you getting you know give
me examples the last three times you
know something bad happened like how bad
was it sometimes we if its approach so
that one might be a bad one to just send
to in this case fort is the general
manager for the Makani project if it's a
safety thing that maybe just sending it
to him isn't the right thing to do but
for some you know as long as it's not
like for its a bad person and I think he
needs to go like then we should just
give it to fort and say hey this is a
real concern what do you think often not
always they actually will then respond
on this pre-mortem thing in the
conversation and frequently they will
ask for more feedback so if the concern
is we're doing the wrong thing okay
thanks i appreciate like you're
concerned that does not really tell us
very much about how we should address
that can you be more specific about what
you think we're doing wrong we're going
to slow but that one happens a
non-trivial amount okay that might well
be true but that doesn't really tell us
what to do about that can you be more
specific before we understand how to
route it to people yeah so you mentioned
two different kind of questions to ask
when you get these ideas how is this
going to push the boundaries but also
how
you can will see this so do you ever get
ideas that maybe don't score evenly on
those two questions and maybe or
something like a device that can harness
energy around this side and in five to
ten years you can learn a lot about that
device and you can really push the
boundaries in technology but in fact ten
years that would be writing for market
is that still something you would
explore so the question is what happens
if something looks really incredibly
promising on the technology front but
weak or only very delayed maybe it's
great but 20 or 30 years from now on the
business front or vice versa it looks
like a great business but it's kind of
weak on the technology front in both
cases again because of our bias about
the difference between the false
positives and the false negatives we
mostly say no we're not perfect
reasonable people can disagree you know
often there are some people who think oh
there's no nothing hard on the
technology front here let's not work on
this and then someone else says that's
because you're not a mechanical engineer
you don't understand that this is like
totally rocket science to make this
thing happen that's just been proposed
so we do have some of those debates but
once they net out usually if they don't
have both of those things in healthy
doses we won't do it and that means we
throw out 99% of the stuff that even
that we talk about seriously but that's
probably it's still cheap because a
hundred hours on every single one of
these things throwing that 99% of them
is still rounding error on the amount of
total energy that we spend at X on the
stuff that becomes mature so if
something is 20 years out from actually
being something that we could bring to
the world have real impact on the world
I wonder whether that's the right the
best way for us to help humanity
relative to finding something that's
only seven or eight years out working on
that waiting you know and then 10 years
from now let's get back to that idea of
yours when there's only 10 years till
it's going to change the world yeah are
you organizing all that knowledge so
that
and so the question is how do you
organize the knowledge that most people
can benefit from it there's two aspects
to that one is when we come up with an
idea internally or someone else gives us
the idea and then we go through the
hundred hours worth of work and we
decide it's not the right idea where do
we write that down internally so we
don't just like keep reinventing the
square wheel over and over again no it's
a square wheel that's no good when we've
in fact already sorted out like ten
times square wheels aren't any good
we're okay but not great at that we have
repositories internally for doing that
so it's not that we don't write it down
but how it gets shared could be better
the thing that kind of saves us from
that at least internally is that we have
a relatively focused group the rapid
eval group so they all know where the
repository is so people in other parts
of the organization probably don't know
that it's there but the people who are
really responsible for figuring out in
those early days is this around wheel or
a square wheel they know where they've
written down their own failures and
everyone else's failures sort of these
post-mortems about why it actually
didn't work out separate issue is when
we discover that something isn't a good
idea how do we tell the world about that
it's complicated in various ways for
intellectual property reasons there's
too many to talk about some of them like
the one you just conceptually brought up
we might not really have killed we might
just be pausing for 10 years but I just
mentioned two in my TED talk recently
one was about these lighter-than-air
variable buoyancy cargo ships and so we
were just sharing with the world some of
the basic reasons why we decided not to
do that someone else might decide to do
it another one that I mentioned was
vertical farming and why we got stuck on
vertical farming why we couldn't get
past a certain point on vertical farming
and we've had a lot of people somewhat
bristly come back and say well but I
still believe in vertical farming hey
that's cool we're just setting my weed
and the reason we didn't do it is
because we couldn't figure out how to
get staple crops like grains rice to
grow in vertical farming if you want to
grow like microgreens I go crazy
vertical farming is awesome you know and
that might be a nice business and it'll
seem cool you're not really going to
change the world or like feed billions
of people you know making microgreens in
some 30-story farm that's not like
potatoes rice corn wheat like those
things are the kinds of things that if
you can't do any of them it's a little
less plausible that vertical farming
would really change the world so we just
described that to the world as a sort of
and in fact in my TED talk I told people
explicitly if you know how to do this
come tell us because this is what we got
stalled on if you have the the missing
piece for us we'd love to resuscitate
that project so we do do that I think
it's not out yet but we just had a big
project or that wasn't huge but it was
really near and dear to our heart it was
a good number of people working on her
for kind of a while inside X we really
wanted this one to work out we had some
working prototypes it just felt so good
and we've killed it recently and we're
publishing a paper anyone have the date
on like roughly when that's coming out
not this year all right all right so
except you're just like nature or
something like that so as soon as we get
it through that process it'll be out to
the world so we are serious about
sharing yes then our technology and
traditional business how much I hope
these things if I beat applicator is
nothing for example that's big heavy
trash something and I see opportunity of
transplantation idea Jessie and using
that technology to change the business
part of the thing but I'm sorry for the
culture and so any part fun should I
will be partly that is it not technology
the question is how much is what I'm
describing transplantable or not
transplantable into an organization
which isn't trying to be a moonshot
factory which might be a smaller
business it might be a less
technology-focused business or whatever
that is I don't think there's anything
about what I said we're focused on
working on things that are big hard
technology problems
that's a detail that's specific to us
there's nothing about what I said that
you could not do except in the presence
of big technology problems that the
technology is just happens to be an
instantiation of it for us but here's an
example which is another sort of example
of the culture in the sort of mid days
of glass I was worried that the team was
going to get less creative as we moved
prematurely into trying to ramp up
manufacturing so you have to take a
bunch of people who are hyper creative
and kind of get them over the wall
culturally into this sort of high
execution mode which is very
uncomfortable for a lot of them and
you're bringing in new people to help
with that process and this often kills
the very thing that you care about in
these early organizations which is the
sort of rapid prototyping and the
creativity so I started a process which
we called the get weirder award and the
get weirder award was given at once
every two weeks and in order to make
sure it was clear to people what we
wanted to reward the reward was given
out for the most creative proposed
experiment and we gave out the award
before the experiment was run so that
there was absolutely no question that it
was not about outcomes because outcomes
you cannot control you as a scientist
you only care about the quality of the
experiment how thoughtful did you design
the experiment how cheaply could you
create the experimental apparatus for
the experiment and by experiment I did
not necessarily mean technology this is
actually answering a question people
from the customer service group won the
get weirder award and from the sales
group and from the marketing group
technology people did designers did but
you can ask a super creative question so
one of the examples that happen was we
had a one-day sale for glass
and we didn't we couldn't possibly staff
up enough people to like man the phones
and answer pre-sales questions so the
customer service group said why don't we
ask all of our existing customers the
explorers for glass if they would be
willing to do pre-sales question
answering it doesn't matter whether it
works that's not the point that was an
awesome question right and and has
nothing to do with technology and your
organization will be successful to the
extent that you get people doing that
asking those kind of questions and they
will only ask those kind of questions
and run those kinds of experiments if
they actually think they can get
promoted for doing that and having it
not work which by the way will almost
exclusively not work it happened to work
in that case it worked really well but
most of these experiments the very ones
that are weird won't work out if they
all worked out if they wouldn't be that
weird like people had already be doing
it so you have to reward them beforehand
you have to reward them even if I might
even say particularly when it doesn't
work out or they just won't do it yeah
I'm wanting about how the structure can
be implemented into expect you don't
have lots of my promotion or like Sal
guys or whatever like how can you
actually culturally engineer situations
by the cops productive social norms you
can have so the question is when you
don't have some of the classic
structures forwarding people like money
or promotions how can you do some of
this culture engineering people don't
even respond the strongest to money
there's a ton of evidence out there that
when you give people a raise in their
salary it has this ridiculously short
life you know like they feel good for
like a week maybe and they totally
forget about it what people want is
recognition they want you to say thank
you they want to believe that their
manager that their peers think they're
cool think they're interesting think
that they'd be worth having on the next
project
think about yourself isn't that what
motivates you the most in the end is
being around people you trust and having
them think that you're special to them
so if you can create any environment in
which people can say to each other hey I
really appreciate that that makes me
think you're special and there's lots of
ways you just give out cool points like
make little pieces of paper that say you
know one cool point and then hand them
out or you don't like that do something
else it doesn't matter what it is but
you don't need cash and you don't need
promotions to do what I'm describing
yeah um you spent a lot of time to begin
talking about culture engineering which
is really fast dating bud it seems like
Cole Trinity requires a lot of power
you'd actually be able but nothing
changes most of us going into our jobs
like we're not going to have the ability
to do all the things you described where
you know towards the bottom so I just
leaving my last job I worked out for
several years because it was really old
tool and not very interesting so what do
we do to try to implement this culture
from the bottom and not so the question
is if you're not the CEO how do you
implement or change the culture and
that's a great question number one good
for you for leaving a boring place that
is itself an expression of power by the
way that is a powerful thing you can all
do and you are disempowering yourself if
you don't do it and I encourage people
to leave places including X sometimes if
this is not the right place for you
don't humor me tell me this is not the
right place for you I'll help you find
another place in some other part of
alphabet or somewhere else in the world
I definitely don't want you here if you
don't want to be here if you think that
were idiots just tell me I'm actually
interested if you think we're an idiot
and by the way people tell me all the
time that i'm an idiot which is a little
bit hard to hear but in and amongst all
the youren idiots I also hear lots of
things that are wrong with ex and I we
fix it like X is the worst moonshot
factory in the whole world except for
all the other ones and the reason it is
is because people believe
it's safe to say what's wrong with it
and then we like surface all the bad
stuff and very slowly we're like taking
care of it so I just had a meeting today
I'm now the proud general manager of a
different group at X that has some some
leader challenges and I was sitting with
someone today I'm doing office hours and
someone came to me and hey how are you
doing and I really know we should talk
about and I said well what's broken oh
there's there's some stuff that's broken
we'll give me an example well you know
Bob over there is working on something
that's you know we could buy for like a
thousand dollars have you said something
to Bob no come on and like Bob literally
happened to be coming to my office hours
like 30 minutes later I said I'm gonna
tell Bob that you think that I'm not
throwing you under the bus but shame on
you for not having gone to talk to Bob
you should run in tell Bob before I die
Bob like don't you want to be part of
something where we're all like
passionate and we're all we have enough
of a sense of urgency that we can't
tolerate that kind of waste that's not
just me having power I'm empowering him
yes but I'm empowering him to be part of
the change that he wants to see and even
if I hadn't done that if he had come to
me and said you know Astro it's been a
little bit crazy here I've been along
for the ride i kind of want to believe
but this particular team within X I
don't know I've my doubts i think our
culture's gone the wrong way I'm this
close to leaving if you have my back I
will make a fuss I will go rally us me I
you know like I'm at the bottom of the
totem pole but I still Bob or Sally or
whoever and willing to be one of your
emissaries to change this and make it
great but you need to have my back Astro
asked for that and if they have your
back go do it and if they don't quit
again go find someone who will have your
back or just be the CEO I think half of
you are sitting in this room because you
plan to just be the CEO so you don't
have to ask permission which is its own
kind of power
Oh totally fascinating please join